[Musique]
qu'est ce que ça peut être à votre avis
un show à la télévision ça peut se
produire par un fil à la masse un court
circuit la poule qui forment les
résistances sont à l'autre et que je ne
connais pas parce que les machines
technique et qualité ne permettent pas
de le presse book
qu'est ce que c'est pour moi c'est un
cerf livre mais qu'est ce qui vous fait
dire ça parce que books est ses livres
en anglais et presse serbe serre-livres
point ça veut dire ça le self control
qu'est ce que c'est je pense comme dans
les lycées mais temps ou dans les
grandes surfaces il ya des seuls
services
il ya des personnes qui sont chargées de
contrôler à l'intérieur si si tout est
en ordre aussi les plateaux sont remis
en place mais ton et si tout se passe
bien si je vous dis le bookmaker par
exemple mais oui et un principe
sitemaker revient sur un an en réaction
à vous mais ma réaction
moi c'est à dire que j'ai pas beaucoup
de doha alors je sens pas tellement bien
mais évidemment quelqu'un qui semble
très bien ça écoeure le le bouquet si je
vous dis le bookmaker pourquoi est ce
parce que vous en pro d2 un bouc
à votre avis sinon le bookmaker bon je
vois pas qu'est ce qu'on ne voyait pas
pourquoi le beau coup de coeur alors le
marketing ça serait un bel après mois
les change de marque dans d'autres
puissance de ses marques largement
sponsorisés qu'est ce que ça signifie
on peut penser à pons pons penser ce
pont c'est ou alors sponges éponges
alors autrement dit sponsorisés ça
voudrait dire nettoyer est ce que c est
rhinois août à insee le reste du temps
c'est le reste du temps c'est à dire par
exemple janvier soyez made in france
qu'est ce que ça signifie
made in france rompt pas si c'est une
marque de vêtements de choses comme ça
non et c'est par tous est marqué made in
france comme ici et pourquoi ils
diraient les anglais c'est par les
anglais alors il dirait vous me le dites
encore une fois en étant je vous dis on
est entre nous ça ne sortira pas des 50
millions de téléspectateurs c'est sam et
dean france alors rumsteck ça serait une
viande de fête au four avec avec du rhum
atom qu'est ce que ça va vouloir dire et
comme ce sont des molécules que l'on
trouve dans la recherche scientifique
qui a des atomes d'entre eux des atomes
dans l'est
la recherche enfin c'est la recherche
worth et ou dans les facultés on
travaille sur les attendent
c'est une histoire de recherche elle
arrêtera trouve être at home par exemple
patent sas a aucune signification ça à
temps c'est ça alors je ne sais pas être
atom l'on sache si parfaite à thomas
c'est difficile je parle actions nettes
at home
c'était mon anglais parce qu'on vit
qu'avec des mots anglais en france alors
on me disait qu atom ça voulait dire à
tous at home
hawat hommes atom à tommy attend oui
mais worms et ses atom à terme non ça
c'est pas la bonne prononciation
sûrement mais qu'est ce que ses atouts
au wat sommes sûrement c'est at home and
ont je crois pas j'y pas d'accord et
qu'est ce que ça peut vouloir dire aux
mannequins hommes ces hommes et moi je
vous dis atom être at home par exemple
en m'excusant de mon accent là ça je ne
sais pas si vous me disiez tout à
l'heure
de quoi comme non mais j'ai parlé des
atomes mais pas de watts hommes non moi
je dis atom mais ça je sais pas ça y'est
pas je ne sais pas
[Musique]